Wir wollen blicken auf die 2. Bundesliga der Männer und heute legen wir einen Schwerpunkt auf den HSV, auf den 1. FC Nürnberg, auf Eintracht Braunschweig und das tun wir mit Anna Lautenbach, Fadi Keblavi und mit Nando Silva. Jetzt hier im Rasenfunk, das ist das Intro, das ihr schon heiß erwartet.
Und das 1-0.
Bevor wir loslegen, ein Live-Ergebnisservice, der euch lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern gar nichts bringt. 2-0 Schalke. Habt ihr es schon gesehen? 5 Minuten gespielt, Kenan Karaman hat gerade das 2-0 gemacht. Vor allem ohne Zuschauer, da entfaltet dieses Start in seine wahre Pracht. Nando würde wahrscheinlich zustimmen. Also ein etwas anderer, ungeplannter Start in diese Sendung. Aber ihr hört es schon, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wir nehmen gerade parallel zum nachgeholtem Spiel, zum verschobenen Spiel, Osnabrück gegen Schalke auf. Und nach 6 Spielminuten kann man sagen, ja, Osnabrück wohl abgestiegen und Schalke 04 drin. Sollten sie mich das Lügen strafen, dann werden wir es vielleicht auch noch live während der Sendung erfahren. Also schön, dass ihr hier seid, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und schön, dass ihr drei hier seid. Als Erstes wollen wir mal so allgemein auf diesen Spieltag blicken. Jetzt sind wir quasi schon live eingestiegen mit dem verschobenen Spiel. Nando, vielleicht willst du mal anfangen, jetzt jenseits von allen HSV-Themen, die wir gleich noch besprechen. Was war denn für dich noch wichtig an diesem Spieltag?
Doch wir haben uns gefreut.
Also später hat er mal auch sein Wappen gezeigt. Das hat er glaube ich noch nicht gemacht.
Gegen Pauli muss man das tun.
Ja, aber natürlich interessanter Hinweis, also so gut die Abwehr von Braunschweig ist, die von Wien-Wiesbaden ist noch ein Treffer besser. Und deswegen steht er tatsächlich gerade bei der identischen Tordifferenz. Und das könnte wirklich noch relevant werden. Auf der anderen Seite, ich will jetzt auch hier natürlich nichts jinxen, aber wenn ich mir zum Beispiel allein die Situation von Kaiserslautern angucke. Die sind vier Punkte vor, die spielen jetzt als nächstes bei der Hertha. Was haben sie bei der Hertha geschafft? Die sind im DFB-Pokal weitergekommen. Und die können da den Nichtabstieg klar machen. Und dann wissen wir doch, wie dieses Heimspiel laufen wird gegen Eintracht Braunschweig. Dann sind die im Kopf beim DFB-Pokalfinale und könnten ja sowieso das Witzigste überhaupt machen. Wenn sich jetzt alle in der 1. Liga um den 8. Platz ketschen und dann wird Lautern Pokalsieger und der 8. Platz, reicht für gar nichts mehr.
Ja, ja, das stimmt. Wir haben auf dem Betzenberg nie besonders geglänzt. Ich glaube, das haben auch die wenigsten getan. Die größte Chance ist wahrscheinlich wirklich das Heimspiel jetzt gegen Wiesbaden am Sonntag. Das wäre wirklich, wirklich gut. Ja, und würde mich auch einfach sehr freuen, weil ich finde, dass der Verein viele gute Sachen im Moment macht. In den letzten sechs Monaten viele gute Entscheidungen getroffen hat. Ich empfinde die Stimmung im Moment als positiv, als konstruktiv, als nach vorne gewandt. Und zwar ohne dieses, hey, wann steigen wir wieder auf? Sondern du hast halt im Braunschweig einfach Bock auf 2. Liga, ins Eintracht-Stadion gehen, Hannover 96 endlich mal wieder schlagen, sowas. Also gar nicht irgendwie die großen Sprünge. Und ich glaube, diese Genügsamkeit ist im Moment ein total nachhafter Boden für eine Fußball-Fan-untypische Zufriedenheit mit dem eigenen Verein. Und das würde mich einfach kolossal freuen für Benny Kessel, auch für Marc Pfitzner, der ja wirklich am Tiefpunkt aller blau-gelben Seelen letzten Herbst diese beiden Spiele geleitet hat, wenn das klappen würde.
Ach, Anna, und man merkt doch einfach, was für ein gottverdammter Podcast-Profi du bist, indem du Hannover 96 erwähnt und gleichzeitig dissed, indem du sagst, naja, Hannover 96 besiegen, also gar nicht so große Sprünge. Wie schlau, ihm einfach so noch einen mitzugeben. Ach, einfach gut. Aber auf einer Skala von 0 bis 100, wie ätzend ist es, dass der vorletzte Spieltag nicht mehr zeitgleich stattfindet? Denn es gibt ja auch, ich meine, für euch ist es von Vorteil, aber es gibt ja ein Szenario, dass Hansa Rostock auf Schalke keine Punkte holt. Und damit wäre ja der direkte Abstieg schon gar nicht mehr möglich für Eintracht Braunschweig. Also es ist in dem Fall jetzt für euch gut, aber irgendwie fühlt sich das falsch an. Wir alle wissen, warum es so ist, wegen Geld natürlich. Aber schade.
Das wäre schon geil, auch Bundesliga. Ich meine, irgendwie ist da ja der größte Drops auch schon gelutscht. Aber mehr Bock macht es schon, wenn es einfach parallel alles stattfindet.
Ich würde deswegen ganz gerne mit euch allen drei noch mal kurz auf das Restprogramm im Tabellenkeller blicken. Weil in der Tabellenspitze haben wir es vorhin mit Düsseldorf und dem HSV eigentlich schon ausführlich besprochen. Mehr kann da jetzt auch nicht mehr passieren. So ist das halt. Aber im Tabellenkeller. Also Schalke können wir, die führen immer noch 2 zu 0, haben mehrere Chancen aufs 3 zu 0 vergeben, wenn der Ticker der Sportshow hier richtig ist. Die können wir rauslassen. Dann haben wir eben Nürnberg zu Hause gegen Elbersberg, dann beim HSV, Lautern in Hertha, dann zu Hause gegen Eintracht Braunschweig. Braunschweig logischerweise jetzt gegen Wien-Wiesbaden und dann in Lautern wie in Wiesbaden logischerweise gegen Braunschweig und gegen St. Pauli dann. Und Hansel Rostock müssen wir noch mit reinnehmen. Die spielen dann eben auf Schalke und dann zu Hause gegen Paderborn. Fadi, du das mal beginnen. Wann macht der Club fertig? Oder wird man jetzt wirklich gegen Elbersberg zu Hause auch verlieren?
Ich hätte einfach gerne, dass einer von euch dreien mir jetzt vorrechnet, dass der Club trotz zweier Niederlagen sowieso überhaupt nicht mehr absteigen kann. Damit bist du immer in meinem Herzen. Ich nehme diese St. Pauli HSV-Peinlichkeit wieder zurück hier mit. Das war eine super Aktion von beiden Seiten. Oder nicht nur vom HSV. St. Pauli sind die Bösen.
Ich kann es auch wirklich erklären, weil ich auch vorhin meinte, ich freue mich, dass Lautern in der ersten Liga bleibt, weil ich einfach davon ausgehe, Braunschweig gewinnt ihr Heimspiel. Und Rostock holt keine drei Punkte, und dann ist das Thema durch. Und dann ist es egal, wie Nürnberg spielt, wie Lautern spielt, dann kommt da Wiesbaden nicht mehr hoch. Der 34. Spieltag könnte gar nicht mehr im Abstiegskampf interessant sein. Ich habe da großes Vertrauen im Braunschweig. Ich persönlich. Ich glaube nicht, dass Rostock irgendwie noch die fehlenden Punkte holt, auch nicht bei ihrer Tor-Differenz. Und dann ist das Thema eigentlich am Wochenende auch im Abstiegskampf gegessen. Deswegen war meine Aussage nicht gegen Braunschweig anders, sondern eher, weil ich glaube, dass das Thema für Lautern auch durch ist, weil da unten Wiesbaden irgendwie nicht mehr rauskommen wird.
Alles klar, dann betrink ich mich jetzt.
Du kannst auch gerne betrunken nach Kaiserslautern fahren. Du musst eingelernen.
Kommt ihr an Nürnberg vorbei?
Ja, wir können sie nicht schlenken machen. Wir müssen uns nur einigen, ob Wein oder Bier. Alles klar, Wein, gerne.
Als jemand, der mal ein 0 zu 0 von Lautern gegen Union auf dem Betzenberg gesehen hat, kann ich sowieso empfehlen, da nur Betrunken hinzufahren.
Das habe ich jetzt schon von mehreren gehört.
Es gibt da gute Weinschorle, deshalb ja.
Ich meine, ich wollte schon das Gegenargument einführen, aber es ist doch am letzten Spieltag immer noch spannend. Aber wäre es ja noch zwischen Wiesbaden und Rostock, also dann, während die Relegation kommt, das wäre die Spannung. Also sprich, wir sind uns alle einig, ihr seid alle gerettet und der HSV steigt vielleicht noch auf.
Bitte nicht.
Nicht solche Hoffnung. Das wäre doch die Pointe für all die HSV-Saisons, als der Jäger oder der Gejagte es nicht geschafft hat. Und jetzt eben dann einmal hat man halt selber so einen Slip irgendwie in der 104. Spielminute dann durch einen Strafstoß, der vielleicht nicht so ganz eindeutig ist. Und dann Relegation gegen den Erstleagisten. Was soll schiefgehen?
Ja klar, also das wäre natürlich die Hollywood-Geschichte schlechthin, wenn das Ganze sich jetzt am letzten Spieltag komplett drehen würde für den HSV und du dann auch noch die Relegation überstehst. Aber darüber will ich wirklich nicht nachdenken, weil das macht nur irgendwie ein ungutes Gefühl. Und dann sitzt man hier am Freitag und dann reicht es nicht gegen Paderborn.
Und dann nee, nee, nee.
Das ist zu, zu...
Ich traue euch das absolut zu nach der Stunde jetzt. Wenn es einer schafft, in die erste Liga aufzusteigen, dann der HSV.
Das muss man jetzt aber auch sagen, wie euphorie-trunken du bist, seitdem dir Nandu gesagt hat, dass der Club nicht abbleibt.
Wirklich. Ich nehme Urlaub und fahre nach Kaiserslautern mit Braunschweig und so. Alles cool.
Es ist so wunderschön, hier zu sein.
Wir sehen uns nächstes Jahr alle wieder.
Das ist doch super. Ich würde mich darüber freuen. So eine Runde wie mit euch, die moderiert sich wie von alleine. Auch wenn ich einschränkend sagen muss, ob jetzt ein Aufstieg des HSV wirklich Hollywood-reif wäre oder ob es dann nicht doch vielleicht nur für die Bavaria-Filmstudies hier von meiner Hausruhe reicht, das würde ich mal noch zur Diskussion stellen.
Ich würde mir auf jeden Fall persönlich auch wünschen, da würde ich mich dann nur anschließen, dass der Kandidat aus Rostock den Weg runter antritt.
Dazu habe ich im hinrunden Rückblick ausführlich geäußert. Wobei da ja wieder ganz andere Themen dranhängen, weil wenn die Vereine dann aus der Sichtbarkeit verschwinden, passieren noch schlimmere Dinge. Schaut euch an, was jetzt bei Aachen so passiert ist, als sie mal ein bisschen aus dem Licht der Öffentlichkeit weg wären. Glückwunsch zum Aufstieg. Aber Leute, ihr habt Hausaufgaben. Das ist nochmal was Eigenes. Aber gut, im Grunde müssen wir jetzt die letzten Spieltage gar nicht mehr abwarten. Wir haben es hier ausführlich besprochen, wie es laufen wird. Ich freue mich auch, dass wir hier mit so guter Laune rausgehen. Anna, du musstest auch gar nichts jinxen. Das haben wir alle anderen für dich übernommen.
Nanu übernimmt die mathematische Verantwortung. Sehr gerne. Ich habe total Bock auf die nächste Zweitligasaison. Die Aufsteiger aus der 3. Liga sehen gut aus. Die Kandidaten aus der Bundesliga bringen noch mehr Publikum runter. Dann wollen wir mal sehen, über was wir uns so unterhalten an Sensationen, wenn wir zum Ausgang Kiel gegen Heidenheim gucken.
Ja, das ist aber jetzt noch ein ganz anderes Thema. Schön, dass du jetzt mir noch mal einen reingewirkt hast. Aber gut, so verteilt es sich fair unter allen. Ihr drei, es war eine wunderschöne Runde. Fadi Keblavi, Nando Silva, Anna Lautenbach. Ich werde natürlich verlinken, wo man euch alle hören und wo man euch folgen kann. Es sei auch allen Hörern und Hörerinnen sehr ans Herz gelegt. Danke euch dreien, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt für den Rasenfunk. Und euch lieben Hörern und Hörern danke ich natürlich für eure Unterstützung, denn der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt pale wall werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Und in dieser Folge danke ich Blutin Olli, Don Bratwurst1848, Maxi, Stefan K., Krokodok, Igor P und Les Ink. Sie alle haben uns nicht nur unterstützt auf rasenfunk.de slash-supportersclub, sondern sie haben sich dort auch registriert als SupporterInnen. Und dementsprechend konnte ich ihnen hier danken. Ihr könnt uns auch auf kiosk.rasenfunk.de den letzten Merch noch wegkaufen und uns so unterstützen. Und ihr könnt uns sehr gerne weiterempfehlen. Das wäre auch so schön. Schöne zwei Spieltage euch allen noch. Bleibt gesund, bis bald. Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.